so kelly you've convinced me that i
should be wary as i as i browse the
internet
what should i be doing to make sure that
i can i can leverage the internet but
not get into trouble
well i think it all starts with where
you're connecting to the internet um so
first off like you it's a great if
you're using your own device which you
trust
and your own wi-fi network at home or at
work that's kind of the safest option uh
when you're traveling or when you're out
and about now to cafe that's where you
know the internet can start to get a
little bit more risky just by nature so
um you know the worst thing could be a
computer like in a hotel lobby where you
can log in to get your your um pass or
your
boarding pass printed out and because
you don't know who else has used that
computer you don't know what they put on
it that's completely you know risky it
could be that they've downloaded
something to spyware onto the computer
it could be that they've plugged
something in that's dangerous um you
know it depends if you're just doing
something safe like looking up a local
restaurant that's pretty low risk but
once you're starting to think about
typing your username and password into a
computer that's where i would personally
be a little more cautious um you know
and then also you can think about free
public wi-fi networks um you really have
to think about if you trust the network
so a lot of times you know most sites uh
use hps encryption so that means between
you and that site everything you're
saying sending is private uh it doesn't
mean the site is safe it just means that
you guys have a private connection
so i make sure i understand this point
especially if you're using a public
network to ensure look at the url see
the https
instead of the http before
as part of the url
then you at least know that the
communications between you and the site
is private you just have to make sure
it's not a shady site but at least other
people on that network aren't going to
be able to see what your password is or
what you're typing and things like that
yeah exactly exactly
you